now the 8 news now investigators looking
into a controversial Nevada gun control
bill it is known as the red flag law
that law allows for family members in
close relations to petition the court to
have their loved ones weapons taken away
just by applying but as Nate news now
investigator Kyle Payne explains almost
no one is using it and it seems to be
having very little impact on the
Region's murder and suicide numbers
come here
give me your hand police body cam video
from September of 2021 metro police
chasing and cornering an armed gunman
and eventually shooting him to death
waiting to know if we had to go help out
the government tonight the suspect Trent
Leach all over Tick Tock with videos of
himself and his handgun a believer in
gun rights to say the least Mr leech's
Reckless and dangerous actions not only
endangered the lives of the officers but
the lives of citizens who live in the
neighborhood Las Vegas Metro held their
standard press conference and called it
Case Closed still breaking here at five
o'clock a man telling police to shoot
him before opening fire at officers but
the 8 News investigators stayed on the
story and uncovered documents that show
Trent Leach never should have had a gun
buried in the 63-page report on his
shooting is Las Vegas Metro's admission
that they'd tried to take Leach's guns
away two months before and again one
month before he got killed one of only
17 red flag law applications filed in
Clark County population 2.2 million
since the law passed in 2019 the law
allows people to get a court order to
take away a dangerous person's Firearms
I would note that they've heard nothing
on their red flag issue at all Senator
point of order single time the 2019
State Senate meeting got a little testy
because the red flag law was added as a
last-minute Amendment to the gun Bill
introduced by Democratic state senator
Sandra houdegi you have all heard my
very personal story and why this issue
is so important to me how to give us at
the mass shooting on one October and her
gun bill was in part a response to that
with the promise that the high number of
gun homicides and suicides in Nevada
would drop I'm here because I believe
this policy can save lives but the
policy may not in fact be saving lives
there were 69 gunshot homicides the year
the bill passed in 2019 but by 2021 it
skyrocketed to 118 and suicides by
gunshot 223 in 2019 and 280 last year
they have not made it easy to use it
at all Jared dalhauer is a nurse
practitioner at human Behavioral
Institute in the West Valley he used the
red flag law once to try and take a
patient's guns away and the court denied
his application it should have gone
through it seemed like a clear
reason for uh temporarily taking a gun
away from a person Dr dalhauer said he
downloaded the red flag application form
but that there was little to no
instruction on how to fill it out or
what to do with it so he sent his
employee here to the Regional Justice
Center where his employee waited in line
for an hour and a half and never got
waited on and in the end the medical
professionals dealing with a life or
death emergency had to send their red
flag application by U.S mail I would
like it to be effective but it does not
seem to be effective at this time it is
the red flag law a flop
yes Republican state senator Scott
Hammond says the red flag law isn't
working because it's underused and
unconstitutional but it has been several
years now and with little usage I think
it's because people don't trust it well
you don't want to mess around with
people's due process rights I mean it's
so American I think a lot of people who
are opposed to this bill will worry that
it's going to be overused words of
support for the red flag law from state
senator Dallas Harris a Democrat who
voted for the bill part of the issue
here is it's impossible to prove the
negative right we will absolutely never
know how many lives have been saved from
a temporary
restriction on on gun owners gun owners
who only face a thousand dollar fine if
they violate Nevada's red flag law Kyle
Payne 8 News Now
when Governor Lombardo was running for
office he promised on his campaign
website to do away with the red flag law
and others like it calling them quote
Antiquated state senator Harris who Kyle
featured in that story says that will be
nearly impossible to do with Democrats
now in both the assembly and the state
senate